[Musik]
ein eher verschlafenes Dorf mit 10.000
Seelen plötzlich im Blickpunkt der
Weltpolitik Augustdorf
im Schatten des Hermanns zwischen
Bielefeld und Detmold im Nordosten
Nordrhein-Westfalens gelegen und für
weltweite Aufmerksamkeit sorgend die
Generalfeldmarschall Rommel-Kaserne und
der dort beheimatete Kampfpanzer Leopard
2 von hier aus wurden die ersten 18
Panzer in die Ukraine geschickt die dort
bereits eingetroffen sind mehr als
ursprünglich geplant denn nach
anfänglichen internationalen Druck auf
die Bundesregierung endlich Panzer zu
liefern halten sich eben diese Länder
nun zurück eigene Panzer zu schicken
der Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 feuerstark und
modern international war der Druck auf
Deutschland groß möglichst viele zur
Verfügung zu stellen und deren Ausfuhr
zu genehmigen dann die Zusage der
Bundesregierung 14 werden geliefert
ebenso viele sagt Polen zu Kanada 4
macht 32 versprochen waren zwei
Bataillone das entspricht in der Ukraine
62 Panzern mindestens es fehlen noch 30
er nüchterung bei Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius im ZDF heute journal es
bestehe nach wie vor die Hoffnung dass
wir ein bis zwei Bataillone zusammen
bekommen aber das hängt jetzt im
Augenblick nicht mehr von Deutschland ab
sondern von den anderen Partnern die
sich ja vor der Konferenz in Ramstein
auch entsprechend geäußert haben helfen
zu wollen und das müssen wir jetzt
zusammentragen
Leopard 2 zu liefern dafür machten
Spanien und Portugal zusagen aber wie
viele sie exportieren das ließen sie
offen die Niederlande sprachen von 18
Leopard 2 Panzern ohne feste Zusage nur
wenige Länder haben sich auch in Sachen
Leopard 1 zusammengetan Deutschland will
zusammen mit Dänemark den Niederlanden
und Belgien insgesamt 100 liefern 20 bis
Mitte des Jahres
unabhängig von der EU haben die USA 31
Kampfpanzer vom Typ Abrams zugesagt und
Großbritannien 14 Challenger 2
militärisch sonst auf Augenhöhe sieht
sich Frankreich doch das EU-Land hat
sich bisher nicht entschieden ob es
einen Kampfpanzer alle klärk zur
Verfügung stellt es gebe gar nicht genug
so Experten und französische Politiker
behaupten die Ukraine wolle den Lehrer
gar nicht
den gegenüber steht dieses Video der
Clark dazu Chanson Musik
[Musik]
ins Netz gestellt vom ukrainischen
Verteidigungsministerium Botschaft die
Ukraine braucht Panzer auch aus
Frankreich
durch das Zögern der europäischen
Nachbarn muss Deutschland mehr liefern
eine Schwächung der eigenen Truppe die
Panzer gehören zum Panzerbataillon 203
in Augustdorf es ist der
Verteidigungsminister der hier
persönlich einfliegt Boris Pistorius
muss der Truppe die von sich selbst sagt
sie stehe mehr oder weniger blank da
erklären warum es wichtig ist 18 Panzer
aus dem knappen Bestand abzugeben und
damit noch blanker zu sein das ist für
die Ukraine gut verstärkt die Ukraine
ganz sicher aber es ist schlecht
natürlich die Einsatz und
übungsfähigkeit und wir werden
unsererseits alles tun um die Lücken die
das gerissen hat vorübergehend oder
reißen wird und schnell wie möglich zu
schließen
in Augustdorf lässt sich besichtigen wie
Russland kriegt die Bundeswehr Amerika
Grenzen bringt der bittere ist Zustand
sieht so aus
von den 290 Leopard Panzern in den
Bataillon der Bundeswehr sind keine 90
einsatzbereit auch in Augustdorf sind 5
Leopard Defekt neue Panzer wie Pistorius
die verspricht könnten wohl frühestens
in drei Jahren geliefert werden wenn er
das wirklich realisieren will dann muss
er in der Regierung mit dem Parlament
auch sprechen wie man Rahmenbedingungen
verändert denn er muss in den nächsten
Monaten bestellen damit diese diese
Ersatz in dieser Legislaturperiode noch
realisiert werden kann der Truppe in
Augustdorf fehlt es nicht nur ein
Panzern und Munition sondern wie überall
in der Bundeswehr an viele mehr
historius hat klar gemacht dass die 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen aus seiner
Sicht nicht reichen werden aber für
schnellen panzerersatz braucht ihr die
Rüstungsindustrie die macht klar sie
braucht langfristige Verträge was wir
nicht machen dürfen wir dürfen nicht nur
ein Jahr denken und wir müssen was
ändern bei der Budgetierung denn wenn
Sie heute fünf bis zehn Jahre
Planungssicherheit haben brauchen Sie
natürlich auch für fünf bis zehn Jahre
Geld und das hat das ab heute nicht ja
der Prozess ist hier limitiert und ich
denke das muss angepasst werden die
Gespräche mit der Rüstungsindustrie
genau dazu liefen sagt Pistorius da sind
sie ein paar konkrete Arbeit draufträge
erwachsen auf beiden Seiten an denen wir
jetzt
arbeiten und dann geht es hoffentlich
sehr schnell voran es war jedenfalls
sehr sehr gute Gespräche die Hoffnung
machen dass wir da jetzt mehr Speed
reinkriegen in die Frage
wie denn das ist etwas wofür besonders
die Bürokratie in historius Ministerium
bislang hier weniger bekannt war Speed
erhofft sich das Panzerbataillon 203 aus
Augustdorf jetzt auch nach dem Besuch
des Verteidigungsministers für den
Kommandeur Oberstdorf müssen nun in
Worten auch Taten folgen
welche Auswirkung hat denn jetzt konkret
für Sie die Abgabe der Panzer
die Abgabe von jetzt insgesamt 19 unser
Leos tut natürlich weh
und hat natürlich Auswirkungen auf die
Ausbildung und übungsfähigkeit auf den
ausbildungsübungsbetrieb im Bataillon
gut und wichtig ist dass wir noch über
ein Minimum ein Kampfpanzern verfügen um
unser Nachwuchs das heißt Richtung
Ladeschützen unseren
unteroffiziernachwuchs und Offizieren
Nachwuchs auszubilden
die Ausbildung am Simulator rückt
natürlich jetzt in den Mittelpunkt aber
klar ist auch ohne Kampfpanzer geht es
nicht wir brauchen
Kampfpanzer denn den Führerschein
erwirbt man ja auch nicht am Simulator
sie sind in ihre Soldatinnen und
Soldaten mit dieser Information
umgegangen oder mit der Entscheidung das
ausgerechnet von ihrer Einheit die
Panzer abgezogen werden
die Stimmung ob der Abgabe der
Kampfpanzer ist natürlich gedämpft
aber ich denke die Mehrheit der
Soldatinnen
ist sich darüber im Klaren dass es eine
klare Notwendigkeit gibt die Ukraine zu
unterstützen in ihrem Freiheit ja
Überlebenskampf und dass wir hier im
Bataillon auch die Last nun zu tragen
haben was braucht die Bundeswehr was
braucht ihre Einheit weiter an
Unterstützung um effektiv arbeiten zu
können
wir haben ersten Februar war ja unser
Bundesminister hier um einerseits noch
mal das rational für die Entscheidung
Kampfpanzer aus dem Panzer bei den 203
abzugeben hier zu erläutern zweitens hat
er sich ja auch den Fragen gestellt und
drittens hat er natürlich auch die
Perspektive aufgezeigt dass es um
Nachbeschaffung das heißt um Ersatz
gehen muss schnellstmöglich und das ist
das was wir brauchen jetzt fragen sich
natürlich viele Menschen wenn man so ein
Panzer sieht wie schwierig ist das so
ein Panzer zu bedienen zu fahren was
würden Sie einschätzen braucht ein Mann
eine Frau um dieses Gefährt bewegen zu
können
also wenn man Grundkenntnisse hat das
heißt ein Auto fahren kann dann kann man
die Grundlagen des Fahrens und das
Bedienen des Fahrzeugs sicherlich in 1
bis 2 Wochen vermitteln aber
diese Kampfpanzer sollen in wenigen
Wochen in der Ukraine im Krieg
eingesetzt werden und dann muss man das
Fahrzeug beherrschen das heißt unter
Stress und schwierigen Bedingungen damit
umgehen können der Leopard 2 ist ein
Kampfpanzer des Heeres aus deutscher
Produktion der 1979 in Dienst gestellt
wurde er wird ständig neuen
Anforderungen angepasst die aktuellste
Variante des Leopard heißt A7V wobei das
V für verbessern steht
Herr Oberstdorf der Leopard Panzer ist
ja in aller Munde und jeder möchte ihn
haben was zeichnet in diesem Panzer aus
was macht er so besonders
ein sehr guter Kampfpanzer und meiner
Meinung nach sicherlich einer der besten
der Welt
Kampfpanzer
zeichnen sich durch drei Komponenten aus
und wenn das Zusammenspiel aus den drei
Komponenten nämlich Beweglichkeit Schutz
und Feuerkraft gut aufeinander
abgestimmt ist dann sprechen wir von
einem guten und sehr guten Kampfpanzer
und jetzt fangen wir mal an mit der
Beweglichkeit hier
hinter sitzt das Triebwerk 1500 PS und
das macht den Kampfpanzer Leopard 2
besonders beweglich und Beweglichkeit
ist nicht nur dass ich Raumgewinne
sondern ich muss schnell
Stellungswechsel also aus dem Stand aus
dem Feuerkampf ausweichen können wenn
Feind Auftritt um dann an anderer Stelle
wieder neu anzusetzen
also auf der Straße sicherlich 80 90
km/h im schweren Gelände bringt er immer
noch seine 30 bis 40 km/h und das ist
schon eine gewaltige
Angriffsgeschwindigkeit
wenn der Kampfpanzer dann auch noch den
ein oder anderen Treffer einstecken kann
nämlich eine über eine gute Panzerung
verfügt umso besser und letztendlich der
dritte Punkt und der Kern ist natürlich
die Feuerkraft und hier hat der
Kampfpanzer
mit seiner 120 mm klapprohrkanone der
Leopard 2 natürlich große Vorteile und
kann den Feuerkampf von oder bis zu
3.500 Metern präzise aus dem Stand aber
vor allem auch aus der Fahrt führen
jetzt die beiden Einstiege einmal für
die Ladeschützen das heißt hier wird die
burgkanone geladen anders als bei
russischen Kampfpanzern
lädt also kein ladeautomaten und ich bin
davon überzeugt
der Ladeschütze die Bordkanone schneller
laden kann als ein ladenautomat sie
nachladen kann und hier dann zu sehen
einmal unten den Platz des Richtschützen
und darüber den Platz des Kommandanten
der Richtschütze hier vorne seine Optik
Tag und nachts sehfähig und es genauso
das hier die Optik des Kommandanten
genauso Tag und Nacht sefähig wie wird
so ein Panzer eingesetzt also wir sehen
hier das ist eine eine eine
ablenkungswaffe die man hat wie würde
das jetzt normalerweise funktionieren
also Kampfpanzer wird im Rahmen der
Verteidigung aus Stellungen eingesetzt
im besten Fall
sind die vorbereitet oder geschoben so
dass die Silhouette des Kampfpanzers der
ja doch mit drei Metern ziemlich hoch
ist in einer Deckung verschwindet und
von da aus führt er mit der Bordkanone
den Feuerkampf nach einem Schuss ist die
Stellung verraten deswegen hat jeder
Kampfpanzer auch eine wechselstellung
und um diese dann auch schnell zu
erreichen braucht es Geschwindigkeit
wenn der Kampfpanzer durch den Feind
aufgeklärt wurde ist er natürlich ein
Ziel und
der Sicht durch feindliche Kampfpanzer
kann er sich halt entziehen indem man
hier rechts und links sehen Sie die
nebelmittel wurfanlage diese einsetzt
und vor sich einen
Nebelschleier legt so dass er durch den
Feind nicht mehr erkannt werden kann
die modernen Panzer Leopard 2 technisch
auf dem neuesten Stand doch eben für die
Ukraine kaum verfügbar eine Lösung
könnte da der Vorgänger sein der
eingemottete Kampfpanzer Leopard 1
seit Monaten drängt die Ukraine darauf
die von der Bundeswehr vor Jahren
ausgemusterten Leopard 1 Panzer zu
bekommen rund 100 davon stehen in einer
Halle der Rüstungsfirma FFG in Flensburg
schon Mitte letzten Jahres hat die FFG
in Berlin den Antrag auf
Ausfuhrgenehmigung in die Ukraine
gestellt der Regierungssprecher gibt
bekannt die Leopard 1 können und dürfen
geliefert werden kann ich bestätigen
dass es eine Auswirkung dass eine
Ausfuhr Genehmigung erteilt worden ist
viel mehr möchte ich zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt nicht sagen das wird sich dann
in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen noch
konkretisieren womöglich die ersten
Leopard eins der FFG könnten in etwa
drei Monaten geliefert werden später
dann mehr weitere 88 Leopard 1 hat der
Rheinmetall deren Wiederherstellung
dauert bis Anfang nächsten Jahres
erklärte das Unternehmen vor ein paar
Wochen der Leopard ein sehr ungefähr
vergleichbar mit vielen Panzern die
Russland Einsätze und er sei ein großer
Stückzahl verfügbar von daher sage ich
mal ist das besser als wenn wir 14
kaufen
das letztendlich auch im Blick auf die
Verluste der Ukraine an Menge Problem
werden wird Leopard eins wurden in viele
Länder verkauft dort soll nun auch
Munition eingekauft werden offenbar gibt
es noch genug davon der Vizekanzler
verspricht bei einer Fabrik Besichtigung
in Schweden
wir werden wenn die Genehmigung richtig
vorliegt noch mal alle Fragen
beantworten aber es ist erklärt der will
in der Bundesliga
den Weg frei gemacht hatte wohl die
Entscheidung für die Lieferung von
modernen Leopard 2 Panzern letzte Woche
die alten Leopard 1 sollen zusätzlich zu
dem bereits angekündigten zwei
Panzerbataillonen geliefert werden
wir stehen jetzt hier einem Leopard 1
Panzer hier ausgestellt quasi als
Museumsstück inwieweit kann denn ein
Leopard 1 der Ukraine noch nützlich sein
was die
sichtsysteme angeht und die Fähigkeit
vor allem aus der Fahrt zu treffen sind
sich Leopard 1,5 und Leopard 2 A4 sehr
ähnlich natürlich ist die Feuerkraft
aufgrund der 105 mm Kanone etwas kleiner
auch das Schutzniveau mit Blick auf die
Panzerung etwas geringer als beim
Leopard 2 4 aber mit Blick auf Mobilität
die Fähigkeit sehr präzise aus der Fahrt
zu schießen
ist ja immer noch ein sehr guter
Kampfpanzer der ist mit den älteren
T-Modellen russischer Bauart ich sag mal
bis zum T-72 aufnehmen kann und
dementsprechend für die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte von Nutzen sein kann
vorerst muss die Ukraine mit wenigen
Kampfpanzern vom Typ Leopard 2 auskommen
weitere Lieferungen werden aktuell noch
europaweit verhandelt welchen Vorteil
sie nun der ukrainischen Armee bringen
wird sich nun im Fronteinsatz zeigen